legend tells of a band of noble
guardians sworn to vanquish evil and to
save our kingdom they remain lost in the
mists of Ga'Hoole hidden to all those
who believe you're gonna give a damn s
you have a soft head so I'm filled with
stories and dreams is nothing wrong with
dreams my soldiers it is fine to take
the owl kingdoms are doing something
terribly wrong and you're gonna need to
fly a long way to get to the Guardians
you mean they're real all right
you're gonna find the Guardians of
Ga'Hoole you all come this far each
protecting the other
a fighter
there was some really scary beast out
that way you can breathe now what are
they really doing here they've built an
army powerful enough to take over all
the owl kingdoms the guardians on his
ways of finding religion
he will become waters you too can be a
great guardian
I figure didn't count on this
come on sorry we're not finished yet boy
the taste for adventure arriving to the
tree the first time legend of the
guardians the owls of ga'hoole
knock-knock
he's there out out - that's right Baloo
did I have to hear any more of his
ridiculous our jokes ladies